c'est avec un soupir de soulagement que
les shadows que de la lune avait vu le
marin tombé dans l'eau enfin ils
allaient pouvoir partir tranquille dans
l'espace à la recherche d'une planète
plus hospitaliers et malheureusement
c'est beaucoup car pour tout vous dire
la main d'oeuvre au thon faisait shadox
n'était absolument pas qualifié pour ça
tout le monde sait en effet que pour
voyager loin intersidéral mans parlant
il faut pomper autant et même beaucoup
plus avec la tête avec les plis et la
main d'oeuvre aux shadoks la malheureuse
n'était absolument pas musclé de ce côté
ce qui me revenait d'abord et avant tout
c'était une bonne main d'oeuvre
intellectuelle et pour ça on a les
lâches mettre la main d'oeuvre un régime
spécial sévère et accélérer à base de
calcul le concentré de culture générale
sur activer de bons théorème fonda
moutons atomes crochus tu l'as bien gras
et quantité de machin comme saf
intellectuellement très nourris ce sous
la direction du professeur shadow co la
future main d'oeuvre interstellaire
shadow mon père intellectuel